Next, let's look at creating some weight map based materials.
So weight maps are black and white maps that define where certain layers
and your landscape material will show up.
The weight maps can generally be generated in your external DCC
and then imported to respect the layers inside of Unreal Engine.
So you can generate these maps by hand,
but just make sure that you note the size of the landscape that you are creating
so that you can create things to the correct scale
and then you can therefore import them correctly.
So looking at a material that supports the weight map pipeline,
the material can be set up in a similar way to how we just created the hand painted material.
So we can use the layer blend node,
and then once the material is set up, we still want to apply it to the landscape again in a similar way
and then open the landscape tool, which you can see here on the image on the right hand side.
So the size of the layer weight map will be the size of the overall resolution when the landscape was created.
So in this example, the size of the layer weight map should be 249 by 249 pixels,
which you can see on the left hand side here.
But if you are not sure what size, you can always just right click on the layer from the menu,
select export to file, which is the option that you'll see in the list there.
And you can then export that layer to say a PNG file.
So once you have a layer weight created, you can then import it by right clicking on the layer it is associated with
and then select the import from file, which you can see the image for here.
So you will get a warning if your overall resolution wasn't set correctly.
So just make sure the source file is related to the overall resolution and then you can click import.
And then here's an end result of what you might get when you have a weight map material.
So with this method, you can see some really nice natural looking results here.
The image was made using World Machine to generate the height map.
And then the weight maps and then the material was set up just like in the hand painted material example we just went over.
However, each layer was imported from a third party app.